WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM AT
MEMBERS MUST BE PATIENT AS FAR
STARTING AS A SUB.
BUT WHAT YOU HAVE A SUPPORT
SUPPORT MISTER GRAYSON
[inaudible]
FOR THINK YOU ANY
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
SCENE NINE ANY MEMBERS AND ON
SUPPORT [inaudible]
OPPOSITION.
SHOWING NON MISS IRWIN IF YOU'D
PLEASE JOIN US WHEN MAKE CORN
THAT BE FANTASTIC.
ALRIGHT SEEM --
NINE MISTER GRAYSON WILL YOU
WILL HOLD YOUR BILL UNTIL WE OWE
[inaudible]
FOR THANK YOU.
SIR TERRY WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL SINCE WE DO HAVE FORMED
[inaudible]
I HEAR [inaudible]
EARLIER.
I WE HAVE A QUORUM SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON MISTER GRAYSON SPILL <c.green> BE.</c>
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY AND THE
MOTION IS NOT.
WAIT A SECOND PROMOTION.
THERE'S REAL A FIRST FROM MISTER
SALSA SECOND FROM MISTER LEVINE
AND THE MOTION [inaudible]
AND AND THE ARROW [inaudible]
MATHIS I
SO TO TO CALL THE
ABSENTEES AND SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
MISTER GRAYSON YOUR BILL IS OUT --
MEMBERS I'M GONNA HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE NEXT FIVE MINUTES.
FOR OTHER MEMBERS YOU HERE NOW
[inaudible]
THEY
SECRETARY WOULD YOU CALL
THE ROLL FOR ABSENTEE MEMBERS
AGAIN [inaudible]
GALLAGHER I
SECRETARY WE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
I'VE [inaudible]
ALRIGHT.
THANK YOU OFFER THE EXTERIOR
WE'RE CLOSE